hello welcome to a special LIVE debate
violent britain gangs blades and bullets
were here the community center in
Brixton which tries to put trouble teams
back on the right path by teaching them
to box and they're having quite honest
success we'll be finding out more about
that in the next half hour
they're also going to be talking some
former gang members we're going to be
talking to politicians and to the
Assistant Commissioner of the
Metropolitan Police I've asked them
about what's behind the new surprise in
violent crime and what can we do to make
our streets safer while the Mayor of
London Sadiq Khan has held a crisis
summit with the Home Secretary today on
how to tackle violent crime following a
spike in the number of fatal stabbings
and shootings in the capital and he says
government cuts have left too many holes
that's as Alex Home Office documents
suggest police cuts have possibly
contributed to a surge in violence well
let's just look at some of the figures
here in London more than 50 people have
been killed since the start of this year
alone and most of those are tragically
well I'm joined now by Pastor Lorraine
Jones whose son Dwayne was not to death
while he was trying to save another
boy's life and it's his name that this
centre has been built and from small
beginnings we've had enormous success
have any 400 kids coming through here
yeah we've got so many kids and in all
honesty Jane we're at a crisis point
even though we're helping so many kids
like hundreds and thousands of kids are
still at risk but yes my son started
this boxing project in angel town and
you know I'm really thankful for the
police a Lambeth police Richard wooden
and short obviously they literally took
my hands and provided this space and
said look we're going to help you and
they've been true to their word over
three years now growing up it you know
as a mom and in the community did you
fear something like that could happen
with it was it in the back of your mind
when he went out the house or did you
always think hang on I've got a sensible
boy here Jane I've have experienced the
harsh
grunt of what you finance is has is
doing and doing often came home to me
sometimes and tears and he said mum it's
so dangerous out there it's it's it's
it's caused by them out there and Jane I
I didn't know how violent it was and to
Dwayne was killed and as a mother I I
you know I felt like how why can I grasp
the seriousness of what he was saying
maybe I mean what I'm doing now I should
have been doing then to advocate for the
young people because literally there
were no facilities and I've experienced
a harsh brunt of what my son repeatedly
was telling me about the streets so he
was you think crying out he was trying
to get a message to you and to others
about what his life is like do you think
people are listening to the children now
though he was crying now not just for
himself but for many others I mean my
house was like a community center
because they don't know community
centers so I often had loads of kids
coming to my home I always feed them and
fire them on the sofa and the cries of
the youth are not being heard to the
magnitude that is needed I mean they
work in relentlessly huge aid but Weber
even another young boy in South London
killed found in the Thames another
family reaching out to me asking me for
workers to support them that's it that's
how it is now who do you blame who do I
blame right now it's not about blame
it's about us coming together and truly
supporting the grassroot workers that
have got connected with the kids we've
got a new movement called the gang
that's guiding children in the right
direction and they were out in their
neighbours
slight over a hundred making a stand
it's these groups that the government
need to bring to the table inject the
resources so we can get this done
Lorraine you're passionate about this
and there's no surprise at all thank you
very much thank you gonna be looking at
some of that footage actually from that
gang's meeting later in the program well
let's look at the latest figures from
the home office now these show a
significant spike in knife and gun crime
offenses reported in England and Wales
knife crimes were up 21% last year
compared to the same period in 2006 and
nearly 7,000 offenses with guns were
committed last year which has arrived of
20% on the year before now that means
that every 12 minutes of last year
someone was either the victim of either
knife or gun crime well let's talk to
some of the youngsters that are seeing
this on a daily basis first of all let's
bring an alley alley I'm gonna stop your
boxing and catch your breath
oddly Nora did and you're 16 and you're
boxing here and turning your life around
gruesome we've all got will put some
some other guys that you know gonna
speak to you first only to you first of
all gangs there's this this word gangs
all of us hear about what did it mean to
you being in again so you understand I
wasn't in the game but my area I should
say is gang affiliated
so you once you word in it you were
affected by it I wouldn't really say
affected by it I just lived where those
type of fiends
what what kind of things are you talking
about that were a part of your life that
you saw around you I guess around
violence and
do you think you've got desensitized to
the violence to be honest I just kept my
head low and I didn't really go out that
much to join in the newest Venus those
activities the bottoms really helped ya
boxing has really benefited me as a
person mentally and physically has kept
me away from negative people thanks very
much charlie let's bring in some of
these other guys this is controller a
midi ants as you likely know Elijah I
must see you Elijah and also Maya and in
Maumee who are here as well and and to
you first of all you used to carry a
knife you're not anymore why did you
carry a knife main protection well was
that was going to and then the people I
was affiliated with that's what did you
ever have to use it and what was it that
made you stop carrying it then I started
then I started realizing that it's not
really right like the console that I'm
gonna get like when I'm carrying it I
really about your life because I don't
really see myself like behind bars and
do another temple and see my mom would
go through litter what someone has done
done a bit of time as it is a lot and
what what was your experience of being
in it in a gang like and what did you
get out of it I want answer a different
question I want more focus on the
epidemics camera right now so it's not
whether these kids are in gangs or not
you have to understand you know feel
like they belong anywhere else so
they're gonna you don't call it ganging
up they just call it I'm with my peers
that's what's trying to get out you know
we we call it gang so it's word that's
been used the whole time but what in
reality what does it feel like
is it is it basically just you in your
name it's your group of friends
in the world and you're really scared of
blacks and don't know if there's any
phew if you do make it anybody want to
cross by a few you can get a good job or
good career have a bit of that or even
on your own how all those pressures are
so that's when you start burning
yourself and stop caring and then if
you're not valuing yourself why am I
gonna be the person Nixon disrespects me
and I volunteer so then you don't want
to come and televise it now and now that
something's happening why not do what I
was going through before when I was
being effective or lonely or I'm
suffering form I'm seeing people get
stuck or young people do things that no
one's care in to even treat me or talk
to me or help me feel what I'm going
through
they're just maybe my senior and again
putting in a pigeonhole send you to
prison and then just freezing that's the
problem and then
so you know you're saying is that people
have been put in a box and almost
ignored yes and and back to you this
thing about being vulnerable and wanting
help but and society not being there for
you did you did you feel that did you
feel that there were places you could go
to when you were younger and scared and
carrying a knife you've well I didn't
know but I know it was directing me to
it I know actually pointing out I'll go
there it could help you and that it's
not really putting anything else when we
had that play those days let's talk to
the girls now and Emani and Maya and got
you just get a woman's perspective
really what's it like growing up with
boys with knives around you I mean first
of all do you know any girls who carry
knives but when you grow up in this
society where there's a boys carrying
knives when you grow up with it you get
quite desensitized to it you don't it
doesn't really affect us on a daily
anymore it's a norm for us now so it's
not really like really a fixer I know I
know a couple girls that carry knives oh
yeah because like I think cuz it's so
norm
in the society like they just feel like
if I have beef I might as well just
carry a knife because that's like that's
the normal thing to do rather than just
you know a shower and just you know
we've got some police we've got some
politicians here is there anything you
think you ladies first of all that you
would like the authorities to do that
they're not doing now maybe support the
young Young's I see was saying like
support them ILO and my they fool were
bombable and help them to get this off
there because once they're down they
need to make sure they've been brought
up and made bit uplifted and helped in
certain situations lots of people from
just back that the stubbornest like
they're quiet from that poor homes and
they've had support and love at home and
need to support at the home for them to
thrive on con successful one for like I
got working in me meant to work like
you're nodding there I mean it's more
you know you don't need to start doing
feels differently well you don't just
believe that so for the police you know
just police in Senate office out there
to stop and search random people no
one's gonna take that as you know are
helping the cause you know there's young
people and people around they're gonna
to see you're harassing us because we're
in groups and we have nothing else to do
you're gonna come arrest us well give
them something to do don't just give
them money and that youth clubs in and
take their money win in the youth club
I'll shut down and give them projects
and things that they can do that can
reinvest in themselves and then they can
go on and kind of make something out in
ourselves after these projects
politicians will no no I don't even know
what to start of them you don't just
need to just read there at the money
that's it wherever you like doing the
money right now where your resources is
wrong and whoever else like any other
services you don't need to just
understand young people are scared
they're traumatized they're going
through things that they don't even
understand so one is understand
understand what young person
okay so let's put those points to them
because we've got some of those people
there that are responsible for policing
and also the powers that be we've got
the Metropole and Police Assistant
Commissioner Martin Hewitt's here it's
very good of you to come down also the
Labour MP for Croydon Central Sarah
Jones who's also chair of the your
parliamentary group on life crime and
the former Conservative MP for Enfield
North Nick Dubois also an anti knife
campaigner and Martin here to you first
of all the message from these kids is
out and clear
the police don't understand them and the
police going out and doing stop and
search isn't gonna solve the problem I
don't agree baiting it I don't think the
police are going to solve the problem on
their own I mean we don't just go out
and do stop and search it's really
important to say that I mean we're
heavily involved with this club and
engaging with the community and engaging
with young people is a really an
important part of what we do but we do
equally need to be out there and
enforcing the law we've seen this rise
in knife crime we've seen the rise in
the number of injuries and stocking
searches are really important power
allow us to take knives off the street
and save lives but I agree entirely
there's the point about the a cohort of
young people being desensitized to this
kind of behavior and the carriage of
knives is something that really concerns
me and this I think is a moment for all
of us collectively to work together to
try and deal with some of the things
that the guys have already said on the
challenges that they face growing up
because we will keep policing and we
will keep working and we've got lots of
operational activity to deal with those
people who are going out determined to
be dangerous but we need to be
protecting everyone and we need to be
finding ways for young people not to get
themselves involved in this in the first
place Sarah Jones we've got one of the
one of these ladies Fritz from your
constituency and you know they're saying
they need support they need stuff to do
they need community involvement what
what are you doing as an MP to help
these young people well I mean you could
take what they just said and make it
government policy and that's what we
should do young people actually have the
answers to the problems that are
affecting young people that's the first
thing to say is we should listen to
young people and do what they say they
need because they know I set up the all
party group I became an MP last year I
set up a new party group straight away
because north chrome is a real real
issue in Croydon as it is in London as
it is across the country and there were
two parts of it one is policing which is
super important and one is how do we
prevent North crime in the first place
and everything they've just said about
giving young people
that sense of self-worth the support the
love and the guidance that they don't
have at the moment because so many
different services have been cut so
we're seeing in in London for example an
increase in exclusions in schools quite
a big increase so if the kid is excluded
from school for behavioral issues often
because they've got an undiagnosed
mental health problem that nobody's
picked up on and nobody's treating then
they go to people with oh unit they meet
people who are in the same situation and
things blow from there and they get in
trouble because they lose their way and
we're the adults we should be there
intervening and it's for politicians now
at this crisis point but thankfully the
government has now woken up to that we
should all go right this is the moment
where we listen to young people and we
do what they tell us to do no fewer
exclusions longer school days is
something other people have suggested as
well I wonder if any of you think that's
a good idea I mean asking asking young
people to vote for more school has never
never seemed sensible but in the sense
of having wraparound care having places
that kids can go to if their parents are
working long hours would that not be
something you think would work or hell
maybe that making sure they got support
in place and they can able to just fool
like not by their self and making sure
that there's Pacey they can go and maybe
you've centres and stuff like that open
more open more you centers and where
people can listen and not just judge
them for your young people I want people
to listen that's what I don't say sit
down but I don't understand to listen to
what I've got to say I don't think oh
you're doing that I want you to listen
listen listen to me it might not solve
problems with my disabilities let's
bring in Nick Dubois an tonight climate
camp am do you think the adults are
listening do you think the authorities
are all this well I think we have to
seize the moment the the horrible thing
about the tragedy and this huge spike in
deaths is that it is on back on the
agenda big time and if we seize that
moment and that's not just the
politicians I think it is it can be
filled by the politicians they can drive
it but what they've got to do and this
is the difference I think yes bring in
the strategies I really welcome as well
the commitment to new funding I welcome
the commitment to early
intervention programs I welcome to
people looking beyond just criminal
justice and looking at it from mental
health education so but what is still
missing is that we are not reaching
community groups because this solution
will be solved from within the
communities with the full support so
when you come to places like here when
you actually visit other pockets of
early intervention they need the support
the money has to filter to them and the
services and quite often it doesn't what
and in terms of this money forty million
was announced by Amber wrote at the
beginning of the week talking about
things like banning zombie knives
stopping knives being developed limits
people's homes I mean does anyone here
think that's actually will make a
difference no make a difference you know
so the young person has a Mac they're
taking the knife away from us we were
doing you need to get to the young
person of stopping from picking up the
knife in the first place that's where
you love her and wrong and then you know
are just policing them sending them to
jail didn't they get jail they have no
treatment or no helping jobs and they
come out worse and then you are crying
that is epidemic you lot shouldn't be
surprised I can hear the policeman
Police Assistant Commissioner and a lots
been spoken about police numbers let's
look at the figures for example over the
last 50 percent rise and imported
incidents of violent crime over the last
decade in Wales meanwhile same number of
time police officers have decreased by
twenty thousand now you know a lot of
people might say that's not linked but a
lot of people will argue that the PCSOs
the the police support community
officers the people who are out in the
community have gone as well are these
the people that the young people should
be able to talk to should be there will
know the young people this must be
having an effect on what you're trying
to do there's no doubt that kind of
community policing that you described is
absolutely critical to keeping us in
contact with communities because even
though London is huge it's made up of
small communities and small groups in
and around the city and we've committed
to keeping those those neighborhood
teams they are the kind of people who
work with with with organizations like
this but I think the point that was
made is a really important one not to
miss I won't apologize for us taking
knives of people because knives hurt
people and kill people but the point
about that we've been making for a long
time is what we got to get to is a place
where young people don't feel they
either need to or they want to pick a
knife up in the first place because
that's where we've got to get to
actually start preventing this and
that's the kind of work that we will do
with all sorts of other groups and
organizations to try and be out there
with young people giving them that
option not to find themselves in that
situation then there is a we've got to
deal with the criminality that is there
too many people are getting hurt and we
have to deal with that but I take
entirely the point that it can't just be
that kind of that kind of
confrontational work it's about the
community work we do but more
importantly it's about other people
working in communities to give young
people an opportunity to have a
different life but do you not concede
that there must be a link between the
numbers of violent crime and the numbers
of police on the streets because kind of
saying there isn't it's almost insulting
to the police isn't it's always saying
actually it makes no difference there's
no doubt we've we've undertaken
significant cuts in policing across the
country and we've saved lots of money in
London but it's not a simple equation
and that's my nervousness it's not a
simple equation
there's no we are very stretched in
London we're very stretched at the
moment for a whole range of different
reasons but we've been given additional
money to deal with this problem and
we're putting a lot of effort into the
problem but I don't want it to be
oversimplified that it is just
straightforwardly let's put this equals
more private well what can be done to
help here with us now are some of the
community workers who are involved in a
number of projects to try to help the
Animus area first of all let's talk to
Donna Sinclair hi Donna and you run the
options for change support project for
vulnerable families what do you think
about what you've heard from the police
and and from politicians today they're
talking about addressing the solutions
rather than changing policing on the
streets do you think that's a sensible
way forward yes I do
but the police will not be able to
succeed unless they're actually in the
community not just arresting and working
with people who are doing their hands-on
and grassroots work the police also need
to have social care providers beside
them doing the things that are necessary
well the thought that knife is picked up
what is necessary is getting into our
whole soul and making sure that the
legislations that are there to make sure
that these children matter and that
their needs are supported and provided
for is what we need alongside policing
that you know that he believes and
community projects like this at the
police support projects like this it's
it's fantastic that we have something
such a high rank in the police who
believes in this but what we understand
what what we need is for government to
also believe in what the police want to
do I have been working very closely with
in an advisory capacity for a good seven
years or more you know the police they
do engage with the community to a point
but do they have the resources to go out
and implement what I discussed in these
meetings in my experience most times
it's no because they need their officers
to be doing responded to that 999 call
so they're actually they're actually
working to deal with other crises but we
are saying that this crisis now must be
resourced communities must be engaged I
mean I'd like to say that I'm coming
from the page where the community are
frustrated really frustrated because
there are some fantastic ideas out there
in terms of how we could work together
how does ordinary members of the
community who want to get involved be
able to connect with the police and
other service providers to make sure
we're keeping young people say okay and
we're gonna talk to Harry in a second
Harry Hudson oh but first let's bring
the staff and brands I know you've got a
sort of linkage point to that really
listen you you're from and you're from
the found you're the founder of stop our
kids being killed on our street you've
got lots of ideas but you don't think
that authority is listening to you
authority is not listen to us out here
now authorities not listen to us it's
all the MPs are listen to us some of the
police do listen but they did this
higher powers that says well we can't
help him they've got something going on
in mr. car now where are the people is
on a root root root in the trenches
doing the artwork monastry every taking
guns and knives on the street where are
we talking to these people so we can
explain to you exactly how to get around
this problem exactly have to do with
this problem they're not doing it so you
know what we could have to do it
ourselves the community's gonna have to
do it ourselves
how do you get nights off kids well you
know what it's not about barking at kids
it's about engaging with them listening
to them this is one people's feet seem
to understand you can't bark at them
they're not gonna hear that's gonna go
here John it's a baton listen to them
understanding what they want out of life
what they're scared of offenses that
you're going to school you're very in a
gauntlet every day to go to school you
running for a stake through you're not
supposed to be because there's other use
there you
today's responsive go to school in peace
remember these are kids getting killed
kids it's not grown-ups getting killed
this kiss and we've got to stop it the
only way becomes something that is the
community because believe it or not the
MPs and the government is not listening
to the real people and a grassroots
doing the hard work ok well let's speak
to those now let's speak the politicians
at the MPs you're not listening Sarah
apparently well and first so I set up
the oppo a group on North chrome and the
first meeting we had was with 15 young
kids who've been in prison for different
kinds of nikon when we listened to them
and I think you're right people don't
listen enough but I think we're getting
there and we are starting to listen and
the most powerful things I've heard from
the mothers of pick of kids who've been
murdered from the local community groups
that are doing amazing things with no
money organizations like in Croydon
we've got one food gloves not guns which
is similar to here they do fantastic
work with young people but it's our job
you're right it's our job to step up now
and to put the right levers in place so
the mother that I know of a kid who was
murdered her younger son Lee is
massively traumatized because of what's
happened and he's not getting the mental
health support he needs because the
mental health services aren't there so
there are things that we as politicians
need to do but we need to start by
listening to the community absolutely
lecture sites will bring Nick Nick to
bar at forque at serve don't fear I mean
it when you look at amber and you look
at this policy she's announced do you
think you have any idea
truly what life is like but kids like
these growing up well politicians can
always do more by reaching out and being
in the community and and and at home
secretary came to my old constituency in
2017 and met with a lady who had lost
her child ten years earlier and was a
strong voice of the community and did
say what she wanted and what she needed
the difference between saying it and
government reacting well that's been
hard for seven years I've been
struggling to get groups into schools
who will say we don't have a knife crime
problem and we'd say great but we want
your children not to have a knife crime
problem let's get in there and talk to
them these are the groups on the ground
where the government by leading and
insisting and driving a culture change
can actually give the local group
the opportunity to be heard they're here
they know what's going on and government
can empower them more then I think we
can start to make a difference very
briefly Harry because you use football
to try and encourage kids out of trouble
don't you hearing any solutions today
it's the right the messages are right
there's too late it's reacting now to
the problem so really is so right and we
were speaking before we knew this was
coming it's now spiked because we've
left the young who have enlisted young
before such a long time and now I need
to do all the hot doubly hard now when
the problem is so rife in London and we
needs a community c'mere it would be to
be funded but it's so hard it's not easy
for us and the detachment from where we
are at the coalface
to where government level is huge so
you've got we've we hope we have some
politicians here we've had the police
here what about any politicians might be
listening what Teresa may happen to be
watching this why she's having a
sandwich this lunchtime what would you
say to her Elijah you really need to
change your policies or your cracks
years old I don't know how it works or
the fundings or what not so then it's
community do people on the community
ground doing the work and get the fund
and get access to resources not follow
trend in epidemics just a holistic
multi-agency sort of criteria for
funding for the whole of London where
each organization can take money out of
it and do this and in coordinate with
each other and help each other what
you're doing is you're set you're
letting organizations just and
communities and charities just do what
they're doing like I said there was a
girl that's not guns is doing all right
with no that's not you shouldn't you
shouldn't be saying are it's alright
it's good that's not good
look it's not what we need we need
something to be done so if you know that
change and you're going to position to
do so new person I thinking we're gonna
have to stop we're out of time just it's
always a time for thanks to all you guys
for joining us let's see viewer the
images of some of those who've lost
their lives on the streets of London in
the last few months